apprendre à ce prix mais mais aussi
comment jouer en réseau c'est avec
tricky et napo youtuber et streamer que
les élèves de 5e vont s'entraîner sur la
plateforme twitch qu'elle jeudi les tous
les jours avec leurs communautés de
50000 et 770 milles abonnés moi je vais
animer à l'atelier streaming donc je
vais apprendre aux enfants tout ce qui
est géré son image tout ça je vais leur
apprendre les bons côtés comme les
mauvais côtés parce qu'il faut aussi pas
se voiler la face c'est un beau milieu
mais il ya aussi des choses des mises en
garde en fait tout simplement comme dans
tout bon boulot on va dire surtout quand
on est seul et qu'on doit se diriger
seul et à le reste ça va être donc de la
nutrition lis portes de la pratique on
va vraiment les mettre en condition
aujourd'hui en fait des ateliers qui ont
conquis les collégiens qui rêvent à
présent de devenir streamer
professionnel depuis que j'ai 8 ans
jouent aux jeux vidéo
donc ça me dérange pas d'être des
matériels c'est tout ce qui ce que je
veux ça coûte trop cher et la journée
cédant entre mes mains
malgré tout le métier de streamer reste
compliquée avec des obligations comme
faire du sport avoir une bonne hygiène
de vie voire des professionnels de santé
c'est ce que ce professeur de ps
souhaite que ses élèves retiennent en
sport c'est pas forcément très physique
il ya des compétitions donc ça peut
s'appeler comme ça après y'a pas tous
les jeunes sont pudiquement à 6 ans n'a
jeu du fond où justement les deux bouts
d'affaires des mouvements des spots en
musique etc et à just dance aussi qui
existent voilà y aussi des mouvements
il n'y a pas que ça mais après c'est
vrai que le côté physique ou un manque
un peu aux élèves et sajoo ampex sur la
sédentarité en pleine expansion avec
tous les jours de nouveaux jeux comme
fortnight league of legends ou encore
fit pas ce métier du futur séduit de
plus en plus de jeunes qui se lancent
sur le dur marché de youtube